-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
President Biden spoke today
about rising gasoline prices,
but just because alternative
means of transportation
aren't working out.
[ Laughter ]
After President Biden fell off
his bike over the weekend,
former President Trump
said he will,
"Never, ever ride a bicycle."
Oh, nobody thought
you were going to.
I mean, at least
until you said you weren't.
Because if this is anything
like your past promises,
you'll be in the Tour de France
next month.
[ Laughter ]
It did say Tour de France, Baze,
I apologize.
I did it real fancy.
Tour de "Frantz."
That's the Tour de France.
[ Laughter ]
Tour of -- It's the tour of --
President Biden yesterday
signed two cybersecurity bills
into law.
Said Biden, "Hang on.
It's almost done.
Says all I got to do now is
enter my Social Security number
and mother's maiden name."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today
asked Congress to approve
a three-month pause
on the federal gas tax
to help combat rising prices.
And at this point,
he'll try anything.
Don't be surprised if he starts
giving the price in liters.
"Got it down to a buck 39!
Nice."
During yesterday's hearing
on the Capitol attack,
committee members showed texts
that indicated Republican
Senator Ron Johnson
wanted to hand-deliver
a list of fake electors
for then
Vice President Mike Pence
to introduce on January sixth.
You sent that over text?
Dude, how do you send bribes,
Venmo?
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Hillary Clinton said
that it would be
"out of the question"
for her to run for
president in 2024.
Oh, I wait. I read that wrong.
The interviewer said that.
[ Laughter ]
The mayor of Moffat, Colorado,
which has 70 dispensaries
but only 120 residents...
[ Laughter ]
...said in a new interview
that she is considering
changing the name of the town
to Kush.
Said residents, "Yeah, we know.
You said the same thing
like 20 minutes ago."
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in New York City
yesterday
crushed nearly 100 illegal
dirt bikes with a bulldozer.
And 6-year-olds don't know
how to feel about it.
"I mean, I love dirt bikes,
but I also love bulldozers."
[ Laughter ]
That's my 6-year-old impression.
"Come on!"
[ Laughter ]
Health officials in New Jersey
this week
discovered their first
suspected case of monkeypox.
And because it's Jersey,
you know
that's going to be
that guy's nickname forever.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, oh, Monkeypox,
we're getting beers.
[ Laughter ]
You're paying, Monkeypox."
And finally, the food company
Kraft announced today
that it's changing the name of
its popular macaroni and cheese
to Mac and Cheese,
while the people who eat it
for dinner every night
will still be known
as Kraft Singles.
Aw, Goldich.
[ Laughter ]
Matthew Goldich, how...?
Oh, I feel like that guy
is going to meet somebody.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.